I'll tell you what honey well I'm gonna  do if you give me a dress I'm gonna  write you a longer answer and tell you  the exact things I would do okay okay  promise I'll bet you're as bright as  you're good-looking I tell you what  what's your favorite subject journalism  whoa whoa I've been every more  circumspect in my answer those guys back  there go ahead the next question I love  it okay over here Washington Post all  right and by the way that's one of the  things that is dangerous idea you know  as these guys will tell you I'm not  always their favorite subject but the  truth of the matter is the reason we are  who we are is called a free press  continue to denigrate  [Applause]